probably one of the most powerful Fields
you'll also learn in Consulting you're
confronted with new topics all the time
topics where you need to work together
with people who have Decades of
experience in this domain and again you
need to learn to First not be shocked by
this not be paralyzed by this but to
read up on things make yourself
knowledgeable in a short amount of time
we will often have more experienced team
members also with the specific industry
and function knowledge you can talk to
you can interview you will be able
regularly to reach out to internal and
external experts on the topic so there's
a lot about capability building looking
into the knowledge that you need to pick
up but this again empowers you to do
this also in other words Consultants
often are not afraid to step into a new
company in a later role do something
that didn't really do before because
again this is exactly what they will be
doing throughout the course of their
Consulting career